war in ukraine remains an open question
but military posturing on ukraine's
borders continues to intensify
russian troops were meant to leave
belarus on sunday when military
exercises with their ally ended
but their stay has been extended
indefinitely
the bella russian defense minister cited
increased military activity in the
region as well as unrest inside ukraine
but no mention of what ukrainian leaders
and their western allies describe as
russian provocation
the testing of reaction forces will
continue they are directed towards the
prevention of war and our presidents who
have met repeatedly say we don't want
war but we are not being hurt therefore
we created an appropriate grouping of
troops if need be it will bring an
appropriate response
the presidents of belarus and russia met
in moscow two days ago president
alexander lukashenko is a close russian
ally the strategic advantage of having
russian troops in belarus is just one
more reason analysts say president
vladimir putin has the upper hand
this invasion force that's been masked
on the ukrainian border has already
achieved some of its objectives because
he's already got the conversation going
with the united states about limiting
the sovereignty and liberating the
security choices of the country's
neighboring russia about rolling back
the clock so nato protections are taken
away from them and russia can have its
way
[Music]
an estimated 190 000 russian troops at a
heightened state of alert are now to
ukraine's north south and east
their extended mission in belarus only
the latest warning sign that western
leaders say points to an imminent
full-scale russian invasion of ukraine
zain basravi al-jazeera